I've often said we live in an era
obsessed with nostalgia so perhaps I
shouldn't be surprised by the latest
trend taking twitter by storm the trad
wife this is a movement but celebrates
being a quote traditional housewife
homemakers who are happy to submit to
keep house and spoil their husbands like
it's 1959 cue lots of tips for soup
dining etiquette home baked scones and
above all how your husband should always
come first
glorifying the past is rarely based on
facts and the fact that the 1950s was a
time when many women did work for less
pay and with fewer opportunities when
they weren't entitled to control over
their reproductive health where domestic
violence and abuse was often normalized
where feminine ideas were synonymous
with being middle class and white women
fought for feminism for a reason so that
we could have choices if you want to use
the games about activism to raise
children or do domestic work that's your
right but suggesting that the role of a
traditional housewife is somehow the
authentic version of femininity is
actually contributing to the power
systems that oppress us and I for one am
NOT most al jaques for that well I
actually like to come in first on this
cuz I've got serious skin in the game
here is that my wife has recently quit
work to be a well it's remembering the
AIDS of housewife and then as a
homemaker stay-at-home mum is the
American version little hook for
different keys now this is not solely
based on how I feel about and I can
promise you it's not it's not done in
the style of her van Alice been sort of
straightening my tires I go to work you
know she's she's running a house ad you
see the benefits basically to my son my
mum was a home at similar point in my
life and I can't ignore the fact that
that was that was valuable to me and you
know you mentioned the phrase a happy
wife happy life I mean there are a lot
of studies that suggest that this this
is true and I think that a lot of men
will realize that certainly once you've
had a kid as well
that is almost sort of the hub of the
the homes emotional life and everything
flows from that so whilst I look I mean
it's getting it's up my blood pressure
her not working so it's not it's not all
a one-way street I can't ignore the
benefits can i I want to bring everyone
else in and I will but I just want to
clear up a few things cuz I'm not saying
that women shouldn't stay at home I mean
feminism is about choice and I don't
want people to police the choices women
make and I think that what staying at
home is work and I think it should be
valued I mean it's not an easy ride it's
a lot of work I've been at home with the
baby I took a year off when my daughters
born it's really hard work and I think
it is often what women want and it's
good for children if that's the choice
that's made my point is it doesn't have
to be the woman who makes that choice
the man can also choose to stay at home
and also many people are not financially
in the position to have the luxury of
having one parents their home so what my
worry is that when you cast the
stay-at-home mother is the kind of
ultimate women that is so unfair on the
majority of people who don't have a
judgment on the women aren't doing it
why can't you just say this is for me a
valuable thing if we're being
financially independent and working is
so obviously valuable why are there and
I'm not talking exclusively about you
but there's been so many articles where
a lot of people seemed really challenged
by this because women fought so hard to
have the right to be able to make the
other choices I think you know III agree
with your point now in the sense that
the whole idea is that women should be
able to choose yes and actually not
everyone gets to choose this is a very
privileged option right so if we look
any servant I mean you still have the
opportunities that mean that you can
work six seven days a week em be able to
afford to keep a whole household a lot
of people can't sometimes all I'm says
it does involve sacrifice to make it
happen oh I agree I agree and so so this
is a step from 2019 which said that 75%
of mothers with dependent children were
in work in the UK and that's because
they have to be not everyone wants to be
but they have no choice and one last
thing
this is for you Nick and I have found
the event for you
and early May if it's with you you fancy
trip to Florida
well the make women great again
convention is being held and this is
what they have to say women today are
being taught to act more like men where
has that led us skyrocketing rates of
broken families documented decline in
female happiness since the 1970s and
endless social and dating dysfunction no
longer will you have to give in to toxic
bullying feminist dogma and go against
your ancient biological nature as a
woman the men have arrived to help make
women great again before I say my piece
I'm very conscious I've got a nice band
in today where I think you're massively
overreacting I think if there's a
collection of society who wants to live
what was somewhat traditional roles
which has obviously now evolved if
that's their choice that they want to
stay at home and pleasure their man I
don't mean obviously and that's an equal
decision both parties mate what good arm
if the perfect thing was a tasty
spaghetti bolognese me yeah I would feel
very insecure being subject to financial
dominance by him I wouldn't feel
comfortable if I was completely any
nothing and my man held all the power
nor would I for example if I ever got
married
I wouldn't do the vows love honor and
obey because if my bloke ever tried to
get me to obey Him got it be it would be
a long time coming I tell ya so I'm not
into all of that oh that's what you just
said though I know but I don't know why
you're so around up about it so
dismissive you're so let's look at some
of your these women at submit they'll be
making soup and what was it super scary
literally from her
sad wife is ice is what they want to do
that means but what actually done what
is the problem the problem is right but
this movement is casting itself as the
truth woman so this is what women really
are and the problem I have with that is
that first of all it it lets men off the
hook for the fact I think a lot of
working mothers are quite stressed out
we do time spent doing household chores
each week 16 hours women six hours men
and also I'm not saying that there is
anything wrong with making that choice I
respect and I think it should be valued
as well not dismay because I
misunderstood not what I'm saying
is that the idea that what's truly
feminine yeah isn't a make these choices
is exactly what got us in this position
in the first place and I'm just gonna
read you from Harriet Hall she's an
independent journalist for the
independent who says it so well there is
nothing biologically natural about a
woman staying at home cleaning and
darning socks
there's nothing innately feminine about
chastity making home-cooked meals ready
on the table of 6:00 p.m. or adopting a
subordinate position in a relationship
the idea of the feminine is entirely
fictitious a tradition merely set and
ingrained and learned behaviors that
were enforced over thousands of years of
patriarchy so the point is this is
choice choose it but don't claim that
one choice is inherently feminine or
superior to the choices that other
minute we know also the reason I started
just to say I think it's true that a lot
of working mothers are stressed out and
the reason is because men don't share
the domestic work equally and that's the
source of the problem